bonjour à tous bienvenue sur figuerola y
vendait dans les studios du figaro on
est en direct et on attend vos points de
vue notamment sur cette affaire ces
accusations lancées par marie cabrette
celle qui fait office désormais de drh
de charlie hebdo
exfiltré de son domicile pour raisons de
sécurité et qui s'en prend notamment à
jean luc mélenchon qui alimente selon
elle un climat de haine autour de
charlie hebdo on en parle ce soir avec
brice couturier bonsoir bobigny
saronique heures à france culture le
tour du monde des idées tous les jours à
11h53 et auteur notamment de 1969 année
fatidique 7 aux édition de l'observateur
art tout est parti de là c'est ce qu'on
peut lire en sous titre et c'est ce
qu'on peut vérifier en lisant le livre
on parle également avec alexis brézet
comme tous les mardis
bonjour alexis bon sur alexis directeur
des rédactions du groupe figaro le
figaro qui pose cette question sur son
site souhaitez vous qu edouard philippe
reviennent sur le devant de la scène
politique
on en parle mais en deuxième partie
pensez vous comme marie cabrette que
jean luc mélenchon alimentent un climat
de haine autour de charlie hebdo ça
c'est la première question la question
qu'on vous pose sur twitter ce soir cet
après midi en tout cas les députés ont
rendu hommage à cette femme
regardez cette femme c'est malika bret à
la directrice des ressources humaines de
charlie hebdo ce journal et ses
personnels qui sont de nouveau la cible
d'attaqués ignoble alors
standing-ovation pour malika bret qui
travaille donc pour charlie hebdo depuis
1992 depuis l'es2 puis alors depuis les
attentats contre le journal elle vit
comme comme par exemple patrick peloux
qu'on a vu ici hier sous protection
policière ça ne suffit pas la semaine
dernière la responsable rh a dû quitter
son domicile
la suite elle le raconte sur france info
notamment ce matin les officiers de
sécurité - annoncé que j'avais dix
minutes
qui est tu quittais mon domicile parce
que ma sécurité n'était plus assurée
quand ça fait cinq ans que je suis avec
eux des officiers de sécurité sous cette
liste ce genre de choses ça ne se
discute pas je fais confiance en leurs
compétences en expliquer que très
probablement je ne leur ai intégrerait
jamais hélas là c'était effectivement
j'ai difficile c'est difficile à digérer
c'est difficile à digérer et aussi elle
exprime sa colère notamment dans les
colonnes dans les colonnes de nos
confrères du point
une colère dit-elle qui est alimenté par
des responsables politiques d'extrême
gauche et plus loin dit elle jean luc
mélenchon qui alimente un climat de
haine autour du journal brice qu'on a vu
d'ailleurs jean-luc mélenchon l'a
brièvement sur ces images se lever tout
à l'heure à l'assemblée nationale donc
en hommage à marie cabrette
est ce que un climat de haine ou c'est
pas un climat chez jean luc mélenchon de
démagogie comme d'ailleurs elle ne dit
plus loin dans cette interview d'un
clientélisme d'une certaine gauche qui
va à la pêche aux voix de certaines
communautés de certaines inria c'est
vrai la trahison d'une certaine extrême
gauche qui dans notre pays de manière
traditionnelle a joué un rôle essentiel
d'intégration des vagues successives
d'immigration sur une base qui était
celle du rationalisme du socialisme bien
entendu des lumières de la laïcité c'est
très étrange de voir qu'aujourd'hui dans
certaines banlieues communiste comme
aubervilliers en particulier vous avez
afin maintenance est en train de se
calmer mais enfin vous avez eu toute une
tradition dans certains cas dans
certaines municipalités ex-communiste de
flirt avec les islamistes les plus
radicaux
c'est une forme de trahison quand même
assez extraits extravagants
quand on pense à des partis qui se donne
comme extrêmement progressiste très
favorable aux droits des femmes et des
homosexuels et des minorités sexuelles
en général devoir de les voir pactiser
avec le conservatisme le plus moyenâgeux
qu'on puisse imaginer qu est celui du
salafistes or c'est sa femme qui se
produit vous avez une partie de
l'extrême gauche qui joue pour des
raisons électorales d'alliance
électorale et puis de haine de la
démocratie libérale de manière générale
qui jouent le jeu de l'alliance avec ces
salafistes
justement je voudrais pas du tout
l'impression de défendre jean luc
mélenchon je crois que je suis pas
soutenable de ce point de vue il nie et
le pesnel danton va je pense parler
malgré tout il faut quand même
distinguer les choses les gens qui
menacent
comment s'appelle-t-elle marie cabrette
qui menacent risques qui menacent d'y
des brasseries qui menace tous les
journalistes de charlie c'est les
islamistes c'est à lequel al qaïda fait
d'aimer a fait des menaces publiques
contre du charlie au début du procès
récemment qu'ils sont apprises
absolument au sérieux il faut voir que
les cette équipe vit dans des conditions
de sécurisation qui sont
invraisemblables le aujourd'hui charlie
l'adresse ce journal n'a pas d' adresse
on ne doit pas connaître hamas de
charlie il ya des policiers devant des
policiers dehors des policiers autour
des pôles et tous les membres de charlie
vivre entourés de policiers donc c'est
une vraie menace physique qui pèsent sur
quelques journalistes et pas que puisque
les menaces d'ailleurs d'al-qaïda visait
au delà de charlie
l'ensemble de la presse d'hier et la
france et c'est d'ailleurs une des
raisons pour laquelle l'ensemble des
journaux des médias français presse
écrite radio télévision publieront
demain une tribune pour aller au delà
d'ailleurs du seul partant de charlie
mais pour aller au delà au nom de la
liberté d'expression pour dire on est
dans un pays libre n'a le droit de dire
ce qu'on veut et demande en disant aux
citoyens défendez avec nous vos libertés
le droit d'expression donc le cadre
c'est celui-là et et donc il ya les
criminels et il ya ce qu'on pourrait
appeler ce que met en cause assemble de
journaliste de charlie la personne non
par lyon à l'instant voilà exactement
mais aussi fabrice nicolino qui est
captée au qui au début du procès a dit
au fond qu'est-ce qui dénonce l'un et
l'autre ses listes les islamo gauchistes
c'est mélenchon pour le kiné finalement
le porte parole politique
edwy plenel qui en est le parent
porte-parole intellectuelle
dans l'esprit d'un débat public et qui
disent certes dit nicolino je ne les
accuse pas d'être les responsables
directs de cette horreur mais ils ont
participé à sa préparation psychologique
jamais jamais on ne leur pardonnera et
marie cabrette dit des choses pas très
différente elle dit les attentats de
2015 ont poussé sur un substrat chacun à
sa mesure à jouer un rôle détestable
partir des mêmes de mélange de tout ça
quand vous attaquez de cette façon des
gens comme moi comme ceux de charlie en
disant ils ont déclaré la guerre aux
musulmans c'est ce qu'avait dit plenel
il avait dit charlie a déclaré la guerre
aux musulmans
il dit quand vous dites ça vous
justifiez que du coup les musulmans se
venge et les islamistes se venge et
déclare la guerre à charlie donc c'est
une pensée conçue et qui je pense va au
delà de l'intérêt doctorat louis en et
électorales mélenchon au fond il a perdu
sa force de frappe ça et son sens sa
troupe qui était le prolétariat qui
devait faire bloc derrière l'avant garde
révolutionnaire et renverser le
capitalisme o'neal les a perdus et donc
est ce qu'il cherche je cherche un
prolétariat de substitution qui sont les
immigrés et des immigrés les musulmans
et de et de bout en bout derrière les
immigrants les islamistes n'ont pas qui
cherche à s'allier christianisme et
mettre en cause les islamistes devient
dans dans son esprit à mélenchon dans
l'esprit de 2,2 de plenel devient céder
aux crimes d' islamophobie met en cause
islamiste et mettre en cause l'islam
c'est de mettre en cause les musulmans
et c'est maintenant remettre en cause
l'humanité voyez comment le déplacement
et donc partant de là on n'a plus le
droit de ne rien dire il ne faut plus
rien dire car dès qu'on dit quelque
chose on est coupable d' islamophobie
on divise ont et ont créé de la tension
alors justement est ce que pour dépasser
justement la polémique avec mélenchon et
la gauche radicale est ce que c'est un
phénomène qui est cantonné à cette taxe
à l'extrême gauche comme dit marie
cabrel marie cabrette à la gauche
radicale comme vite ou mais quand on
voit des élus macro nist comme comme
sandrine meurent par exemple dénoncé les
députés qui protestent contre la
présence d'une syndicaliste une aide
voilée jeudi dernier à l'assemblée
sans parler des positions d'aurélien
taché ou encore quand on peut lire sous
la plume l'arthur berda quesnel macron
tarder à définir une mine face à l'islam
politique
est-ce que là aussi il n'ya pas aussi un
problème d'une autre nature je le
concède mais est ce qu'il n'ya pas une
ambiguïté même une atténuation de la
situation on va bien voir ce que
comporte le projet de loi sur le
séparatisme que le gouvernement ou
promet depuis plusieurs semaines et qui
est là maintenant sur le point d'aboutir
donc c'est pas mal quand même qu'un
gouvernement accepte de voir les choses
en face et ne continue pas dans le déni
qui a été le fait des gouvernements
précédents depuis quand même pas mal de
d'année aujourd'hui on appelle les
choses séparatisme c'est un mot que
quand même assez fort parce qu'il dit
bompas et oui c'est ce que tu n'aies
l'euphémisation du réel le problème
n'est pas le séparatisme de séparatisme
de mon temps c'était de votre temps de
notre temps c'étaient les bretons les
corps mais de séparatisme si il ya des
ccc des territoires de sécession façon
de ne pas dire les samis oui c'est papa
quand même pour pas visé pour pas visé
oui mais pourquoi ne pas viser oui c'est
ce que dit valls il avec force la valse
à soigner a dit c'était un euphémisme
comme vous donc oui il faut voir que la
république en marche est un parti un des
partis ou pro moment il ya le plus
d'immigrés que je connaisse
en france d'après mon expérience
personnelle et beaucoup de ces immigrés
sont musulmans ils sont pas islamistes
sinon ils seraient pas réplique en
marche jusqu'à être dans un bon outil
mais il ya une espèce de foule et de
bienveillance dans le mail qui est
fondamental dans le maquereau nisme qui
fait qu'on essaie de ne pas monter une
communauté quelconque eux contre la
république autant que possible on essaie
de faire le contre seuil est d'intégrer
les gens de manière aussi harmonieuse et
pacifique que possible donc combattre
gras combattre l'islamisme c'est une
bonne chose parce que les musulmans eux
souffrent sont les premiers à souffrir
de ces l'islamisme kylie kylie qui les
prend en otage dans certains quartiers
donc attendons d'en face quand même le
les gouvernements précédents ont fait
preuve de beaucoup de lâcheté
beaucoup de au nom au nom d'une espèce
de générosité mal comprise en avait
beaucoup de gouvernements précédents au
nom de l'ouverture à l'autre n'est ce
pas invoquer comme prétexte on a vu
beaucoup de ces gouvernements précédents
pratiqué en fait le déni regardez de
regarder de l'autre côté pour ne pas
voir ce qu'ils montaient or là on a
comme affaire à des ministres comme
darmanin dans le maquereau plaisir c'est
qu'ils n'ont plus n'ont pas l'air de
regarder sur le boycot darmanin et
sûrement l'intention qu'il dise des
choses c'est un fait qu'il ait intention
de faire des choses c'est très probable
la question c'est l'effet ratib ne
laissera de son légendaire à le long de
voies attendons d'avoir ne préjugeant
pas de l'avenir on peut quand même
regarder le passé on peut se tirer
quelques enseignements
est ce qu'on observe nous oblige à
considérer qu'il ya quand même une sorte
de gêne idéologique face à cette
question là vous dites vous même
oui on veut combattre c'est la guerre
mais en même temps on veut pas diviser
mais comment fait content pour combattre
sont divisés comment on fait combat pour
combattre sans désigner l'adversaire est
ce que le blues le bas non quand on dit
pas pardon aux portées par le dynamisme
et puis on a parlé du séparatisme
sammis le premier discours de macron à
mulhouse par de séparatisme islamistes
et puis on a fini par parler de
séparatisme tout court dans le privé et
maintenant par le des séparatismes et
donc il en train de forger ce concept d
y aurait plusieurs séparatiste alors je
suppose que dans ses bases et
d'inspiration islamiste j'ose espérer
que qu'on parle de ça mais je crois
comprendre qu'on tire aussi à lire aussi
peut-être le séparatisme des catholiques
des juifs des riches
il paraît bharathi cement j'ai pris des
risques c'est ce qu'on entend dire si
c'est ça je n'aime pas ça je suis prêt
six années passées à applaudir des deux
mains
mais si c'est ça si la rive si l arrivée
de cette fois sur le parking de noyer le
poisson les noyaux de poisson c'est plus
possible si c'est encore pour noyer le
poisson et ne pas dire les choses
ben est bien à ce moment là d'abord ça
sera pas rendre service au pays et deux
prévenus un con je pense que ne sera pas
se rendre service politiquement lui-même
écoutez on a déjà fait un progrès en
passant du communautarisme que l'on a
collé gouvernements précédents accepter
enfin de désigner de ces deux
communautarisme à séparatisme ya déjà un
grand progrès c'est formidable les
bouches s'ouvrent tout de même que notre
part des progrès dans les moules dans
les axes ciblés il nous faut faire des
choses et le problème c'est que dans ce
pays on allait
on a l'habitude de des munichois et des
antilles munichois
il ya toujours eu une partie de la
population et surtout des élites
intellectuelles qui sont habitués au nom
de la tolérance à s'incliner devant la
force en se réclamant de la vertu et de
l'ouverture à l'honneur de meilleurs
sentiments
il faut pas diviser le camp organisé
c'est l'esprit munichois l'esprit d'être
l'éternel esprit munichois que quand on
a dans ce pays parce qu'on on a très
peur de l'affrontement parce que on a
des souvenirs aux rites de la première
guerre mondiale et quand on veut pas on
va parler avec non écoutez moi je pense
qu'il faut quand même saluer le courage
de ce gouvernement parce que c'est au
moins il va y avoir une loi contre le
séparatisme qui va interdire en partie
le financement des organisations
cultuelles qui détournent leur mission
il va y avoir des mesures dont il ya les
associations vont s'engager sur une
charte de la laïcité face et quand même
qu'avoir une chose d'assez nouveau nous
à gina le gouvernement précédent
on a attendu pendant deux ou trois ans
un discours sur la laïcité qui n'est
jamais venue plus de 10 millions d'amis
besoin là on attend cette loi sur le ou
les séparatismes qui devait venir
aujourd'hui
et puis maintenant on nous dit c'est
pendant quinze jours donc attendons de
voir ce qu'il ya dedans oui ceci il
aboie d'approvisionnement c'est de
demander aux associations qui gangrènent
sont deux cités de banlieues qui sont
des associations de propagande islamiste
si le point d'aboutissement seller de
demander de signer le signe qu'elle
reconnaisse liberté égalité fraternité
moi je vous dirais le signerons tout des
deux mains tout décès en citer signerons
pas le signerons elle s'entiche ça
s'appelle la taqiyya au se dissimule
donc faire ça ne vous dira j'ai contre
la liberté l'égalité la fraternité que
faire face moi il faut les fermer vie on
a géré les vingt ans ferme déjà en jouer
en font désormais pas mal de mosquées
mais non on y arrivera
et malheureusement les pas parfois il
arrive qu'ils aient des gouvernements et
des préfets un peu gros jeux qui
essaient les quatre fois sur cinq
leurs décisions sont annulés par le
conseil les tribunaux misrati quel
conseil d'état qui disent on n'a pas
fait comme il faut les règles ont été
respectées
l'imam doit revenir mais d'ailleurs il
est pas si méchant que ça et puis ceci
et puis cela et puis sa famille et est
finalement
rencontre conny les cmos questions
fermées ni les imams sous ne sont
expulsés il y avait notamment le fameux
imam de brest qui a défrayé la chronique
il ya un autre aspect c'est qu'on va
essayer quand même d'empêcher le
financement par l'étranger dans sa
demande de mouvements islamistes et ça
c'est aussi le nerf de la guerre
si on arrive effectivement à es7 cemac
on s'y est engagé personnellement a
coupé les financements de qui viennent
de l'arabie saoudite du maroc ou de
turquie
si on arrive à ça on délivre un centre
de communautés musulmanes de leur patron
et on l'est on les libère on leur donne
on leur donne la chance de s'épanouir
dans le terreau français ça changerait
beaucoup de choses si on y arrive
entrait dans les comptes d'un certain
nombre d'associations est prévu 1 j'ai
pas vu le projet de loi la noix dans le
spectacle à vue et moi j'aime réunion
vague d'inquiétude quand je vois toutes
les réticences des critiques avant même
qu'ils aient quoi que ce soit toujours
privé il est toujours avant d'avoir vu
les choses
nous verrons bien mais ce que je vous
disais
l'expérience permet d' oblige être celle
que j'avais le droit mais était
peut-être pour que ça attendez la suite
nous verrons nous verrons en tout cas il
y à un certain nombre de réactions dans
ce débat et par rapport à cette question
je salut nathan pierre olivier qui nous
rejoignent
olivier qui nous dit jean luc mélenchon
alimentent un climat de haine entre
guillemets ses déclarations à propos de
se marier années de charly sont ignobles
cet autre internaute nous dit en gros
maintenant ce sont les victimes qu'on
emprisonne pour leur sécurité
s'indigne-t-il et babineau qui nous dit
je pense que ce débat dépasse la
personne de mélenchon la société de plus
en plus divisés sur le droit au
blasphème bénigne au qui nous disait
qu'il nous dit tous les médias écrits
devrait être derrière charlie et d'une
manière ou d'une autre publié les
caricatures alors banino ce qui se
passera demain donc ce qu'il disait
alexis il y a donc une grande
déclaration qui va être publié dans
plusieurs des phases dont la liberté
d'expression pas il n'y a aucune
obligation pour quiconque de publier les
caricatures et non ça n'est pas là
l'idée publié la question n'est pas là
question celle de la liberté dans dans
la liberté de blessés mais ce n'est pas
le blasphème qui serait défendue bien
des gens pouvaient être contre la scène
et c'est la liberté le principe de
liberté
c'est ce que l'ensemble des médias de
demain vous réaffirmer et vous répondez
donc à babineau qui nous dit outre la
tribune on peut se demander pourquoi la
presse n'a pas publié les caricatures
avec charlie justement c'est sur les
questions de ligne également qu'ils sont
suivis en tout cas nous dit olivier
c'est très intéressant de lire dans le
dernier charlie les dernières dernières
déclarations des musulmans qui ne sont
pas offensé par les caricatures le la
mosquée de paris vers la mosquée le
réacteur le nouveau recteur guide dans
les colonnes du figaro aux figures boxe
a fait déclarations tout à fait
remarquable et dont il faut c'est le
courage le prédécesseur ne nous avait
pas habitués à de telles déclarations
croyez vous comme la directrice des
ressources humaines de charlie hebdo que
jean luc mélenchon alimentent un climat
de haine autour du journal satirique et
vous avez répondu oui à 84%
il y à une autre question qu'on me pose
sur le figaro qui est un petit peu plus
légère qui concerne cette fois-ci
edouard philippe
dans le figaro de ce dans le figaro de
ce mercredi vous verrez avant qu'on y
vienne que les républicains fourmille
d'idées je ne vous dis pas les qu'elle
voulait des couleuvres vous allez les
découvrir
en tout cas il y a également des idées
pour pour incarner le leadership cet
après midi christian estrosi transformer
son mouvement partie la france
audacieuse ce week-end xavier bertrand
se disait je cite plus déterminé que
jamais pour 2022
bruno retailleau se tient dit on prêt et
récemment edouard philippe a fait
sensation avec cette petite phrase et je
pense que nous allons affronter une
tempête
une tempête économique une campagne
sanitaire une tempête à tous égards
peut-être une tempête sociale peut-être
une tempête politique
je pense que les temps qui viennent sont
des temps difficiles
souhaitez-vous qu edouard philippe
reviennent sur le devant de la scène
politique notamment dans ces temps qui
viennent
brice couturier quand je lis vos tweets
j'ai l'impression en tout cas que vous
préférez que le maquereau nisme penche à
droite mais est ce que l'intérêt de la
droite c'est d'aller vers le maquereau
ni le dal et ça c'est le problème de la
droite et écouter le problème de la
droite c'est ses divisions
c'est pas nouveau voulons n'a dorénavant
une espèce de candidats d'un moment
comme on dit à un moment que xavier
bertrand
on a affaire à quelqu'un qui se prend
depuis ceux qui se proposent sur la base
d'un gaullisme social d'une droite
populaire et sociale donc on voit bien
que c'est l'anti macron puisque macron
il élitiste et intello en face on aurait
une droite qui serait populaire et
sociale bon il ce bon on sait qu'il y
avait aussi
baroin françois baroin était candidat il
paraît qu'il n'a pas envie bon baroin
lui c'était justement une droite
libérale et c'est élitiste alors que
xavier bertrand lui les anti libérale et
il traite ma croûte de libéral
anglo-saxon bon et vous avez aussi une
droite conservatrice avec fillon elle
est pas morte depuis fillon a pris sa
retraite il donc les comptes diverses
composantes de la droite entre la droite
sociale et gaullistes la droite libérale
et conservatrice
la droite conservatrice et pas libéral
il ya toute sorte d'être tellement de
familles que pour arriver à les réunir
les trolls transcender ses différentes
rang et incarner une espèce d'unités
quand même au delà de ses divisions de
plus en plus évidente il faut des
personnalités extraordinairement forte à
la chirac aujourd'hui le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est qu'elle n'existe pas
ça se saurait s'il y avait quelqu'un qui
était capable de faire tout ça à la fois
il n'y a plus il n'ya plus ya pas de
pompidou l'ehpad chirac
donc quel quel est l'intérêt de la
droite je me mets à sa place
bah mon avis ça serait essayez vous
savez ce qui va se passer à mon avis
c'est comme ça qu'on va être élu bien
entendu face à le pen et qu' il n'y aura
probablement pas de majorité à
l'assemblée nationale puisqu'on voit la
réplique en marche c'est un parti qui
n'a jamais existé jamais eu d'existence
et qui est en train de s'effondrer sous
nos yeux
donc il y aura probablement pas cette
fois-ci de majorité il faudrait bien que
mâcon gouverne avec quelqu'un il pourra
gouverner qu'avec deux composantes
soient les écolos socialistes qui vont
proportion se ranger derrière la
candidature de jado soit la droite dont
estrosi à quel s 3 y est en train de
dire puisque macron sera obligé de
compter avec une majorité qu'il n'aura
pas que ce soit nous plutôt que les
écolos là l'idée est intéressante comme
à qu'on puisse choisir ensuite une fois
qu'il serait réélu entre les écologistes
et la droite moi je vous trouve bien
serbe risque bien plein de certitudes et
pour tout dire bien imprudent de dire
que vous êtes sûr que le second tour
opposera macro marine le pen
moi je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils aient
marine le pen je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils
emmanuel macron ce qui me paraît clair
aujourd'hui c'est l'émiettement du
paysage politique est là le fait que
pour accéder au second tour finalement
il va pas falloir grand-chose de flore
20% des vous on a plein de petits
morceaux
il ya un morceau qui aujourd'hui semble
plus gros que les autres vous avez
raison suite de celui de marine le pen
il ya un morceau de macron si on regarde
en marche et les élections ou des
tout-petits si on regarde macro est
nettement plus gros je suis d'accord
c'est le pré mais elle
oui mais n'empêche le malgré tout le
désamour le désaveu dont la popularité
de leurs philippe est le reflet les gens
n'aiment pas forcément être philippe
pour ce qu'il a accompli mais sinon mais
ils l'aiment parce qu'il n'est pas
macron et parce que sans doute il
reproche à ce genre de choses amassé
fabre est ministre quand même c'est pas
fini puisqu'il peut émaner de vacances
est curieux c'est qu'il ya quelque chose
donc
ils ont eu les ressources en énergie
aujourd'hui vous dit il n'y a pas de
candidat pour la droite vous avez
absolument raison
ou c'est vrai il n'y a pas de candidat
pour l'heure je me souviens malgré nous
que quand dominique strauss kahn a
disparu il n'y a pas de caméra pour la
bouche et pas ce pauvre françois
hollande qu'il sera candidat français
vivent ça lorsqu'il a gâché
et puis qu'en france on n'a pas pu y
aller on a dit ça il n'y aura pas de
candidat c'est pas ce petit jeune macron
que personne de koné qui a pas de
parents du québec comme des clarines et
pafilav nous méfiance c'est les
candidats ça peut apparaître très vite
parce que à un moment les gens on a
envie veulent plus de l'autre on va
chercher un troisième donc bien encore
et puis tout cet espace à gauche entre
les écologistes et les partis
socialistes qui aujourd'hui c'est en
tout cas au regard des élections
municipales devient me semble-t-il six
arrivées à s'entendre
ce qui n'est pas garanti mais enfin
quand même on va le voir aux régionales
on a quand même vu un peu dans un nombre
de villes s'ils arrivent à s'entendre
le plus gros morceau aujourd'hui c'est
peut-être on peut très bien avoir demain
hidalgo a second tour marine le pen
hidalgo on peut très bien on peut avoir
un bon tour hidalgo macron à second tour
hidalgo la droite au second tour le pen
la loi aujourd'hui je pense que c'est
extrêmement ouvert bien malin qui
saurait dire quoi que ce soit bon là
dessus c'est sûr que pour la droite elle
vous l'accordé ça serait vu plein de
trouvailles je vous avais le crès
comment ça peut être pécresse ça peut
être bertram and pécresse a peut être on
verra bien ce que l'on voit pas ailleurs
philippe parce qu'il a déjà non non non
il aurait la campagne puma de l'école
voilà il ses campagnes à droite et
humaines mâcon c'est pour toi ou c'est
pour lui montrer où il se dit vu comme
ça tout premier macro si ça se trouve ça
sera pour moi et à ce moment là je ferai
la synthèse des macros nine et de la
droite
ils y pensent évidemment qu'il y pense
et puis aussi nicolas sarkozy qui n'en a
pas envie blé qui y pense beaucoup
le paysage à mon avis peut encore
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup et l'heure
philips et les 80 km heure pour sauver
des vies entre guillemets et le non port
du masque qui a tué des milliers de gens
nous dit pierre xavier bertrand est un
gaulliste social pragmatique
travailleurs qui connaît ses dossiers
estime-t-il bon on voit sous son coeur
balance
babineau est d'accord avec vous
il dit j'ai trouvé la dernière sortie
d'estrosi lui très lucide et
intéressante
l'électorat dlr votre principalement
macron pourquoi ne pas le rejoindre
dire que le lectorat dlr votre
principalement macron je m'assure râle
c'est vrai le cas non non aux
[Musique]
européennes ça c'est partagé en deux
moitiés puisqu'il est bien où il y avait
bien une bonne moitié des élèves enfin
de lectorat traditionnel la connaissez
pas le sais pas lequel on va voir aux
régionales et la aux régionales le
risque du maquereau nice je dis pas de
maintenant je pense que macro à gagner
sans parti il peut regagner ou perdre
100 partis dont les limites sont saurait
dissocier dessus du parti né mais
régional qui pend au nez des macros
liste c'est d'être pris en étau complet
entre la droite d'un côté et la gauche
qui se refermerait autour du ps et des
verts de l'autre
c'est ce qu'on va voir dans la quasi
totalité des régions et puis à estrosi
qu'essaie de et les la droite du sud là
qu'ils cesseraient de sa peau parce
qu'en plus il ya le front national qui
est très très fort et donc les le les
retrouvailles avec les maquereaux nisme
je pense que aussi une d'idées pour les
régionales alors il ya un flight lui qui
nous dit où son coeur balance également
il ya bien sarkozy comme grandhomme
dedans de droite mais on lui a mis les
bâtons dans les roues depuis depuis dix
ans effectivement il ya tant qu il y en
a pour tous les goûts canton lino nos
internautes
babineau nous dit je ne comprends pas
cette obstination dlr a refusé toute
alliance pour l'instant c'est plutôt la
division des à l'idée dé l air pur pour
les alliances parce qu' il a certains
qui veulent tendre la main
à hama cran avec macron je crois alors
on verra après
mais là à part le cadre des dlr du sud
pour des raisons je pense largement
régional e
le mouvement est plutôt à non maintenant
on va pas monter dans le train ou dans
la ou d'en haut sur le titanic on attend
on verra bien si macro est élu c'est une
autre affaire ce qu'est attendu cinq ans
n'attend donc forcément pas forcément
disant cela on va bien prendre et là je
rejoins brice si macron est élu il
retrouvera airframe ajouté parce qu'il
sera élu à droite il offrait une
majorité avec la droite d'un philippe
sera donc mais aujourd'hui je ne crois
pas qu'ils aient une tentation forte à
droite chez les élus les électeurs ça
encore une autre affaire chez les élites
de d'aller vers mâcon il ya une autre
un autre problème que soulève sich c'est
la variable se joue à quelques enjeux de
société
notamment il parle des gp am pm as que
là aussi il n'ya pas y'a pas un problème
entre plusieurs leaders de la droite qui
sont plutôt en tout cas ne sont pas
effrayés par les idées progressistes et
un électorat qui lui n'est pas
complètement acquis et ses idées
notamment en matière peut-être pas sur
les idées sur les questions sociétales
mais sur les questions par exemple
l'identité notamment la même chose vous
êtes sur une droite conservatrice la
droite fillon et puis vous avez une
droite progressiste
c'est pour ça c'est pour ça que cette
droite progressiste aurait tout intérêt
si elle veut s'il veut des places et
ministères et peser quelque peu s'allier
avec macro à l'issue des élections
présidentielles c'est ce qu'elle fera
d'ailleurs en grande partie s'était il
en voit déjà
c'est vous le dites c'est pour les airs
du sud
mais s'il ya d'autres gens qui pensent
pouvoir peser sur l'équilibré
gouvernemental la petite gouvernementale
après 2022 leurs intérêts ce sera
effectivement ce genre d'alliance sinon
mâcon fera alliance avec les écologistes
il n'y aurait que l'économie je vous
suivrai aujourd'hui faire la queue
surtout avec la crise où toute façon
vous jetez dessoude des tombereaux
d'argent
d'ailleurs on sait pas trop pourquoi
mais enfin la droite ferait tout pareil
d'ailleurs y'a qu'à vouloir face
à la fère comme s'appellent de non non
non non non d'aider à payer des prix
stone la réunion les réactions de xavier
bertrand et des ministres mais on se
repose sur les mêmes sont l'espagne et
de rémy demandé son mieux donc s'il y
avait que l'économie je pense que blaise
vous aurez raison mais il n'ya pas que
les libérations régalien et là le
régalien dans la lah il n'y a pas de
droit de progresser au gapeau se
regarder et il n'ya pas non plus de
gauche progressiste sur le régalien
c'est pour ça que ma grande rue y aller
mais il n'y va pas aujourd'hui on nous
verrons mais si en matière de sécurité
d'immigration d'identité de deux
cultures
si sur ces choses là il ne fait pas
mouvement s'il n'accomplit pas la lui
préférer valls ou darmanin le scénar
mannequins kate droit c'est lui les
meilleurs mais c'est les électeurs de
droite ils en ont commandé comme un bébé
sarkozy voilà un complètement égal la
question c'est qu'est ce qui va être
fait c'est ça la question
et si en matière de sécurité
d'immigration de d'identité culturelle
au sens armand rien n'est fait il y aura
une révolte qui ira bien au delà de la
droite car l'électeur de gauche y
compris lectorat populaire de coucher
sur la même ligne c'est pour ça que je
pense que macro aurait intérêt y aller
parce qu'il n'a pas de risque avec les
électeurs il a du riz ça crée évidemment
oui mais mais il a un risque avec les
corps intermédiaires c'est à dire avec
ses députés avec ce son particulier avec
les journalistes avec tout ça le retient
on voit bien qu'il est retenu
on voit bien qu'il ait pas à l'aise avec
l'idée est peut-être qu'il a un problème
avec une partie de lui-même ne porte
qu'une partie de lui-même que vous
deviez très progressive libertaire
bienveillante et bienveillante et n'a
pas envie de deux den1 poignée de
l'opinion vodafone
je suis d'accord il ya une dernière à
l'internaute qui s'appelle françois et
je ne sais pas si c'est une facétie de
sa part mais qui nous demande et bo va
pas recommencer à moins que giscard des
prodiges de ça m'a l'air là se croient
que là quand même non ça va une question
d'âge limite d'âge en tout cas puisqu'on
a pas on trouve encore trouver des
les leaders pour la droite on a des
grandes figures de la droite c'est un
livre qu'on vous recommande qui était
dirigée par jean-christophe buisson et
guillaume tabard et qui revient sur les
grandes figures intellectuelles et
politiques de la droite depuis 1789 et
même avant si je ne m'abuse puisqu'on
commence a écrit marolles et c'est aux
éditions peyrat et on recommande
également le dernier livre de brice
couturier avant ça il faut que je vous
donne la réponse quant à la question qui
a été posée sur le site du figaro
souhaitez-vous qu' edouard philippe
reviennent sur le devant de la scène
politique ça va apparaître et c'est pour
l'instant un léger où il ya 53 % presque
54 et vous pouvez continuer à voter sur
le site du figaro merci beaucoup de nous
avoir suivis à ne pas manquer dans une
heure environ l'interview de françois
berléand et françois xavier demaison qui
remonte sur scène après interruption
pour cause d'eux que vides on attend vos
questions elles seront posées par
charlotte baryons de nuit en direct
merci à très vite sur figaro l'âge
[Musique]